when you build an app one of the main
pain points that you'll face is your
database
you often hear developers debate the
merits of sql versus nosql
on one hand you have safety security and
consistency and on the other you have
flexibility scalability and productivity
but what if there's a database that
could put an end to this debate once and
for all
fauna db is the cloud database that i've
always dreamed of
it's entirely serverless so we don't
have to provision anything and we only
pay for what we actually use beyond the
free tier
it's as easy to use as a document
database and you can manage your data
from its web interface
or the command line it's extremely fast
and scales infinitely in the cloud
and is the first database in the world
to implement the calvin model for
partition database systems most
importantly though is its ability to
handle complex data modeling use cases
like the ones you would find in a
relational graph or time series database
over the next few minutes you'll learn
everything you need to know to get up
and running with fonodb
we'll use it to model the data
relationships that you would find on
twitter
a user has many tweets users can follow
each other and retrieve a feed of tweets
from all the users that they follow
we'll write our code in node.js
and by the end of the video you'll have
an api that you can use to connect to
your frontend application
if you're new here like and subscribe
and check out the full write-up on
fireship io
to follow along today the first thing
you'll need is a free fauna account
once logged in you'll see the fauna
dashboard at this point you won't have a
database
so go ahead and click the button to
create a new one this is what's known as
a top level database
and an awesome thing about fauna is that
it supports multi-tenancy it's beyond
the scope of this video but a cool
feature you should know about a database
can have an unlimited number of child
databases
allowing you to scope data and
privileges to a specific organization or
team
in most cases though you'll just need
one single database for your entire
application
now that we have a database we'll create
a collection a collection is like an sql
table
and works very similar to other
document-oriented databases like mongodb
or firestore a collection is kind of
like a folder that contains many
documents
then you can make queries against that
collection to filter out a set of
documents that you need for your
frontend ui
when you create a collection you give it
a name which is usually plural and in
our case it will store all of our user
data
now a unique thing about fauna is that
you'll also notice an option for history
it retains all of the changes that
happen to a document over time when you
write to the database
fauna never actually changes a stored
document instead it creates a copy of
the original with the changes
then archives the original document to
the history that's extremely useful when
working with time series data
and also for time traveling through any
changes to your data you also have a ttl
or time to live option which can
automatically delete ephemeral data that
you no longer need
now that we have our user's collection
let's go ahead and add a document to it
a document is represented as a plain
javascript object
the data you save here does not need to
follow a rigid structure
however when you query multiple
documents from a collection it's based
on the keys in this object
so if we want to match all of the users
with a certain name or email address
we'll want to use the same key name in
every document go ahead and click save
and now you should see that document in
the collection what you'll notice
is that it's automatically assigned a
unique id to the document
now if we expand the document you can
see in addition to our custom data we
also have a ref property
that points to the user's collection
along with that unique id
the reference is very important because
eventually we'll use it to join data
together from multiple collections
in our case for example we could save a
reference to this user on a tweet
document
so we know who a tweet belongs to which
is very similar to a foreign key in an
sql database
at this point i'm going to add a few
more users to the database and now we
need to think about how we want to
access this data there are multiple
native apis you can use to access data
in fauna the first one that you might be
familiar with
is graphql that's not the api we'll be
using in this video
however if you're familiar with graphql
you can actually upload a schema to
fauna and it will automatically create
the collections and indexes required to
retrieve your data based on that schema
it's really powerful stuff but i think
to really understand fauna you should
learn its custom query language called
fql
you can execute fql right here on the
console or you can install fonichel on
your local system to execute it from the
command line
and a little bit later we'll learn how
to use it in node.js fql is a functional
language
and is very intuitive and flexible but
there is a lot to learn and i recommend
keeping the fql cheat sheet nearby
we'll look at about 10 of the most
common functions but just keep in mind
that fql can do a lot more than i
present in this video
one of the first functions you'll want
to know is get which retrieves a single
document
based on a reference get is just a
function that takes a reference as an
argument we make a reference
with the ref function which takes a
collection and a document id
as its argument if we then execute the
query we get the document data back as a
result
and as an added bonus you'll notice if
we hover over the information icon it
will tell us exactly how many bytes were
transferred
and a bunch of other useful information
now reading a single document is very
easy when you have the id
but in the real world the document id
might not be readily available
and that brings us to our next big topic
indexes an index provides a way for you
to define how to query documents from a
collection
for example we might want to fetch a
user based on their email address or
username instead of the actual
document id a collection can have
millions of documents so an index
provides a way to create a lookup table
to quickly retrieve documents based on
their actual internal data first we'll
give our index a name which in our case
will be users by name
from there we can specify one or more
terms which is a field on the document
itself that can be searched
in our case every user document has a
name and we want to be able to fetch a
user by the name
by default the index will only return
the document reference
but another cool thing about fauna is
that you can tell the database which
values from the document you want to
return
in other words you search a document by
the username and then return the email
address or whatever other data you want
for the ui
that's an extremely useful little
feature and we'll put it to use later in
the video
now let's go back to the shell and we'll
see how we can read a document with this
index
inside of git we'll use the match
function to search across an index
it takes the index as its first argument
and then an array of search terms as the
second argument
in this case we just have the username
which we can add as the second argument
and go ahead and execute the query and
you should get that same document back
as the result
now that we've explored the fauna
dashboard a little bit we're going to
switch gears into an actual nodejs
application
our goal is to build a simple rest api
with express that enables us to read and
write to the database with our own
custom code
by making http requests you can follow
along at this point by opening your ide
to an empty directory
you'll need to have node.js installed on
your system and i'd also recommend
installing the fauna vs code extension
it allows you to see all of your
collections and indexes right here in vs
code which is much easier than going
back and forth to the dashboard
from this empty directory we'll
initialize a new npm project by running
npm
init with the y flag that will give us a
package.json and then we can install
faunadb
and express from there i'll create a
source directory and add an index.js
file to it which is where we'll write
all of our source code
inside this file we'll first require
express which will serve all of our api
endpoints and to interact with the
database we'll require fanadb
and initialize the fonodb client the
client will connect your source code to
the actual database in the cloud
and to do that it requires a secret key
so let's head back to the fauna
dashboard
find the security tab then create a new
key to authenticate your server
by default it gives you the choice
between an admin and a server key
for our use case we just need a server
key however i would like to point out
that you can implement fine grain
access control right here from the fauna
dashboard that makes it easy to follow
the principle of least privilege
where you only grant access to the bare
minimum set of operations that are
actually needed on the server
in any case go ahead and copy the server
key and then paste it into the fontadb
client the next thing we'll do in this
file is start up our express server by
calling app listen
on port 5000 now if you open the command
line and run node
pointed to your source directory it will
start up the server
and keep in mind that you'll need to
restart it anytime the code changes
if that's too annoying for you then
check out nodemon to automatically
reload anytime there's a change
now if you remember earlier i mentioned
that fql is a functional language
and we can import those functions and
use them in javascript from the faunadb
query namespace as you can see i've
imported 10 different functions here
and you don't need to know what they do
at this point the only important thing
to know is that we use these functions
to interact with the database
now let's go ahead and set up our first
api endpoint to read
an individual tweet we'll use express to
set up a get endpoint
that points to a tweet with its id in
the url then for the callback we'll set
up an async function
because any query you make to fauna will
return a promise for this endpoint we
simply want to read a single document
like we did earlier from the shell in
the fauna dashboard
then we'll use the document itself as
the response we can make a request to
fauna for a document
by awaiting a client query query takes
an fql expression as its argument
and remember it's a functional language
so what you end up doing here is
composing multiple javascript functions
together
conceptually it's very similar to
component composition in a ui framework
like react
we'll start with the get function to
read a single document then we use the
ref function to make a reference to the
document that we want
ref takes two arguments one is the
collection that we want to read from
and the second is the document id which
we'll get from the request parameters id
in the url and that's basically all
there is to it the promise will resolve
with the actual document data which we
then send back as the response one thing
we're not doing here though
is catching errors but that would be a
good idea you can wrap the code in a try
catch block or you could simply chain
the catch method to the other end of the
promise
now let's go ahead and test it out at
this point we don't have any tweets in
the database
so let's go back to fauna and create a
new collection for tweets
and then we'll add a document to it with
the text of hello world
once created go ahead and copy the
document id now at this point we need to
make a request to the url in my case i'm
using an http client known as insomnia
however you could just use curl from the
command line or a vs code extension
to make these requests in any case what
we need to do is make a get request to
localhost 5000
tweet followed by the tweet id when we
send it we should get the document back
including the document data with the
text of hello world
now that we know our api is working
we're going to look at some more complex
examples of relational data
in this app a user can have many tweets
but how do we connect a user document to
a tweet document
well first we need a way to create a
tweet and to handle that
we'll create a post endpoint that points
to the tweet url
and then we'll start with the same async
function setup that we used in the
previous endpoint
creating a document is really easy we
just use the create function
point to the collection we want and then
pass it whatever custom data we want to
save there
when we construct the data object we can
use regular javascript values
or we can use fql functions to get data
from the database
in this case we want the user field to
be a reference to another user document
in fauna
there are many possible ways to do this
but one way is to use the select
function
which will select a specific value from
a document which in this case
is the reference now at this point we
might assume we only have the username
in which case we can use our index users
by name
to get the corresponding user document
reference so the main takeaway here
is that you can read one or more
documents when performing some kind of
other operation
like a write to the database and that
allows you to model relational data in a
way that's very similar to an sql
database with foreign keys
and it's also worth noting that fauna is
100 acid compliant
which means when you run this database
transaction it'll be globally consistent
or in other words all future reads will
reflect the value of the right
even when distributed across thousands
of users around the world
if we go back to our http client we can
make a post request to localhost 5000
slash tweet then we should get the newly
created tweet back as the response
and if you go to the fauna dashboard you
should see it created in the users
collection there as well
now that we have multiple tweets in the
database let's create an endpoint that
can retrieve or query multiple tweets
based on a username before we can make
that query we'll need an index
so let's go back to the fauna dashboard
and create a new index
called tweets by user the field we want
to index here is the user reference
to give us all the tweets owned by a
user and because we already have the
user reference we don't really need to
have that returned on
every single document we can tell fauna
to only return the tweet text by setting
it as a value
that way we're only returning the actual
data that we need for the ui
when we make this query it's very
similar to reading a single document
but instead of get we use the paginate
function the difference here
is that git returns the first match
whereas paginate will return a set of
documents
that match that query we then point to
the index and then use select to grab
the reference to the user
now there is one thing that is bothering
me at this point we have some code
duplication going on in our code base
notice we're using the same exact
select code for this query as we are in
the previous endpoint
and getting a user is something we'll do
often so it's only going to get worse as
we move forward
and that brings us to yet another
awesome feature in fauna called
functions
go ahead and copy the duplicated code
and then head over to the fauna
dashboard and find the functions tab
a function allows you to extract some
fql code so it can be used on any server
or any platform we'll give our function
a name of getuser
and then apply it to the server role
then in the function body we have a
query
followed by a lambda function if you're
not familiar with a lambda function
just think of it like an anonymous arrow
function in javascript
the value of x is something we pass into
the function then in the function body
we'll add our duplicated code
instead of the hard-coded username we'll
add a variable that points to x
and then we'll actually change the name
of x to user just to make our code a
little more readable
now we can go back into our node app and
reference this function we'll need to
import call
and function and when you import
function you'll want to rename it
something else using a colon
because it collides with the built-in
function in javascript next
let's find the duplicated lines of code
that we want to replace
now we can call the function by its name
getuser and then pass in whatever custom
argument we want here and it will be
executed by fauna remotely
so if you ever need to update this code
it gets updated throughout your entire
code base atomically
the bottom line here is that functions
provide an awesome way to keep your code
concise
and maintainable what we created is a
one-to-many relationship where a user
has many tweets and a tweet belongs to a
user
what we're going to look at next is the
relationship between users
where a user can follow another user and
or be followed by that user
or in other words a user can have and
belong to many different relationships
it's your typical social graph data
model first we'll go to the fauna
dashboard
and create a new collection for
relationships each document in this
collection
will contain a follower and a followee
whose values are user document
references
you can think of this document as an
edge in a graph that connects two user
accounts together
a one-way graph where the follower
points to the following
back in our code we'll set up a new
relationship endpoint that creates the
relationship document
it creates a document just like we did
for a tweet the only difference is that
we point to the relationships collection
in the data object the follower and the
followee are just user references which
we can get by calling our get user
function that we created previously
for now we'll just hard code a couple of
usernames in here to show that bob
follows fireship we can now go ahead and
make a post request to the relationship
endpoint
and we should get a new document back
that has a follower and a followee with
a user reference on it
now that we can establish a relationship
i want to show you how we can get all
the accounts that are followed by a
given user
and not just the accounts but also the
tweets that are owned by those accounts
so we can show the end user a feed of
tweets from the people that they follow
the first step of course will be to
create a new index which will give a
name
of followers by followee it will take
the followees user reference
then return all the accounts that that
user is following from there we'll go
back to our code and create a new git
endpoint for feed
we'll again use the paginate function in
the query but this time
instead of retrieving a single index
we're going to join two indexes together
the join function takes two arguments
the first one is the initial thing that
you want to query which in our case is
all the followed users which we can get
by pointing to our recently created
index
and then a specific username like bob
that will give us all of the user
references that are followed by bob
we can then join all the tweets from
those users by using the index
tweets by user as the second argument if
we go ahead and make that request
you can see that we now get the text
from multiple tweets back from that
index
and there's a lot more we could do with
joins here instead of returning the
entire index we could use a lambda
function
to filter and sort the results with our
own custom logic but i think we'll save
that for a future video
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there fauna is a truly awesome database
and the more i use it the more i like it
if i were starting a new project today
fauna would definitely be at the top of
my list for the tech stack
if you want to see more videos on this
topic let me know in the comments
consider supporting my work with a
github sponsorship or by becoming a pro
member at fire ship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one